we tend to get passionate about the
things we're passionate about right
technologists are passionate about
technology and they want to build the
best product out there that is like very
sophisticated technology but
at the end of the day if customers are
not willing to pay you for that
then it's not sustainable over time
welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with loamy tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel stanford
welcome everyone to episode 377
i have with me limour sinai director of
solution engineering at akamai
technologies
limour is an enthusiastic technology
leader with extensive experience in
enterprise software delivery operations
and product management
currently a pre-sales director at akamai
technologies
a graduate of mit sloan school of
business she spent her career building
customer technical teams and startups
she also served in the idf and developed
drones for the defense industry
limousinai welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
very good very good i'm after my second
shot which makes me super excited
super exciting it's a new it's a new age
it's a new world
it's a new age it's a your world and
where in the world are you talking to me
right now
uh i am in newton massachusetts which is
a suburb of boston
wow i've never been there before i have
been to boston but not
but not specifically there so limo we
have
a lot to talk about because both on on
the technology center the high-tech side
is a
pre-sales director at akamai
technologies but also a graduate of mit
sloan
school of business which is simply
incredible and
you you've spent a quite meaningful time
in your career building customer
technical teams within startups and i'm
looking forward to hearing about that
but i'm also looking forward to picking
your brain about
the ecosystem in general and as a in
females in the ecosystem we're seeing a
quite dramatic shift in the recent years
i bet that in in many perspectives in my
own it's not
as it's not dramatic enough and it's not
fast
it's slow it's slow it's painfully slow
you exactly i you touched exactly on
where i was alluding to that and i look
forward to hearing your perspective more
on that
and we have some fun questions later on
and i'm looking forward to just hearing
your journey
and picking your brain on these topics
so take me back a little bit but before
we talk about startups and ecosystem
talk to me about gymnastics oh wow
that was way back so i i was that was my
dream
my real dream was to be an olympic
gymnast
and i trained in the us i was a new
yorker
when i got to israel as a teen i joined
the israeli national gymnastics team
and i was training actually with ali
reisman's coach
i don't know do you know aly reisman
from the olympics i know by the i know
about the name but i don't know why
so she was one of the u.s uh
you know one of the us leaders won many
medals in the olympics
quite a remarkable athlete uh so yeah i
trained with our coach
and uh i didn't quite make it there
that's why i moved on to technology it
wasn't that good but it was a fun
experience
way way but you won sixth place in the
wrong road world championship is that
how he said
yes yes run rad so because i wasn't an
olympic level athlete i had to find
another sport runway was the one that
found me
and uh i won sixth place you'd have to
look it up on wikipedia
uh to know what that is i'll challenge
you i'll challenge the group here
i looked it up on wikipedia i'm see i'm
seeing a huge wheel
and it also it almost looks like a
roller coaster yes
it is it's uh literally uh yeah
it's kind of a big wheel that you do
gymnastics on and it was a very fun
sport and uh
at least i made it there sixth place in
the world
well that's a much more than i think i
could ever imagine for myself so
so congratulations on that transitioning
more to mit sloan
school is one of the best business
schools in the world building customer
technical teams
tech ecosystem tell me a little bit
about your journey into the ecosystem
and where you're at right now
so um i've really
spent the majority of my career using
technology to solve business problems
and
and that was even before i came to to
business school
but certainly after and i've done that
in a variety of ways whether in the
services and the post-sales side of the
house
or the sales side of the house and small
startups and larger companies in a
variety of
industries the one shared passion that i
have is always
being on the front lines with the
customer because the customer
is the essence of the business you've
got to serve those customers you've got
to build
products for the customers customers
have to be willing to pay you for those
products
if customers don't exist you're you know
it's it's just not going to work out
um so i'm going to stop you already
because you're
you're explaining it as if it's not
obvious and you're right it's not
obvious to a lot of people why
is it not obvious why um because we tend
to get passionate about the things we're
passionate about right technologists are
passionate about technology and they
want to build the best product out there
that is like very sophisticated
technology but
at the end of the day if customers are
not willing to pay you for that
then it's not sustainable over time i
think
i'm the uh you know i'm the 9 out of 10
startups that are not unicorns and they
don't make it and we and i've never done
a big exit so
i think maybe that's part of my scars in
terms of you've got to have something
out there
that customers are are willing to pay
you for that is sustainable
over the long run right so that makes a
lot of sense and you so you position
yourself in
in the place where you believe and
rightfully so is the most important
p centerpiece of the tech ecosystem but
what does it actually mean to serve
customers and to be
very intentional about that on a very
practical and pragmatic level
um i think we all need to become better
listeners
right so at the beginning when you're
just a startup it's really about
building the best product out there i
think
you know when you're super super small
and you just have a handful of customers
that you're very attentive you're
listening to every single thing they say
and you're putting it right in and you
have that like quick response
time of and and that's the energy of the
startup it's
you you get the feedback you put in and
you get the feedback you put it in and
and that creates a lot of good energy
and a lot of growth and a lot of
excitement
um i think as you grow as a company and
the stuff that i deal with today at
akamai is how do you do that at scale
right you don't have one or two three
customers
you've got thousands of customers and
and you know
companies that figure out how to do it
well on a large
large large scale how do you take that
same listening and the same
feedback and and put it in when the
operation is much larger is a very
difficult thing to do
and and to do it well and so
more tangibly now when we look at
companies and we look at teams that are
built around this idea of understanding
the customers and then
being the front line for the customers
what what as a leader in that domain
what have you learned what are some
things that i perhaps as a young
entrepreneur
soon to be a young founder really need
to keep in mind
as i go about you know thinking about
that aspect of my business
um i think number one listen more
talk less right so listen listen listen
to what the customer is trying to tell
you
um is super critical no matter what size
of business
um i think being genuine
is also really really important um
when especially when stuff doesn't work
as expected so
stuff doesn't always work well um but
being
genuine about what you can do about the
situation i've certainly been in
situations where
we did blue screens of death for like a
bank like a whole bank just like went
down right
and you can imagine those like really
stressful
customer situation where customers are
really upset
about whatever damage you've caused and
whatever
be there don't hide you've got to be
front and center
be responsible do the right thing
i think is the second more most
important factor is because customers
will appreciate you
for being genuine in the toughest
situation um
they they won't walk away when you're on
the hook and when you're willing to go
the extra mile and and do the right
thing
it doesn't sound you know trivial
this thing this idea don't hide be there
you know it's a it's it's a nice
sentence but it
it's far from trivial especially when
i'm imagining a situation like what
you're describing here
where it's a you know a fight or flight
and the nature is to flight
and so it's not fun to take that call
from an
angry customer it really isn't but
that's your actually
those are the make or break moments
those are the make up or break moments
because if the customer
knows that you're gonna be there for
them in those worst moments possible
they know that they want that
relationship
longer term um so so that's why though
and it's very
easy to hide behind something send an
email
i don't know it's always very easy to
hide in those situations as opposed to
just
be there take it all in
shut up and listen right and really to
find a way to do the right thing by the
business whether
you know whether it's free services
whether it's putting more people
on site whether whatever the situation
is there's
always a way to make it more right the
the damage is always done the question
is how do you make it right going
forward
right and i can imagine that you know
it's one thing to talk here in first
person terms and saying
this is how i approach these situations
but at the end
you know in a big organization and
especially as you have teams that are
working with customers it is often not
necessarily the manager that gets the
call it can be any one
of the people that are working on the
team that gets this call and you really
want to make sure that
you know the whole group is aligned for
the same mentality and the same
in the same mindset of being there and
not to flee right so i'm guessing that's
even a much greater challenge than what
we talked until now and as
a leader i think you've got to be there
the most senior leader some of the most
uh the the most amazing leaders i've
worked for and respected are the ones
that took the call at 3am their time
when whatever happened happened and
there is a hundred technical people on
the line to fix it
but they're there as well listening to i
don't know whatever
sir technology problem that they're
going through just
to make it known that they're there to
oversee it
and to do the right thing and that sends
a very
important strong message um to customers
right that makes a lot of sense tell me
a little bit about your perspective on
on the ecosystem we
i introduced it in in one sentence you
rightfully so corrected
my overstating of the of the progress
that we're making
and there is progress it's just very
very very slow
and it's it's probably slow enough for a
lot of people to take credit and to
congratulate the progress
but you're right and correcting me that
that's an illusion for what
for where we actually are so give me a
little bit of perspective
and and help me understand a little bit
better what's actually happening
so i have three girls uh and uh
as such i'm very passionate about how do
we
open up the world of opportunity for for
these girls they're all teenagers today
and how do you change the landscape of
diversity
um when when i joined akamai i joke
there were 10 men in the room i had to
present on whatever technology as part
of my interview process there were 10
men
and literally i the first thing i said
was
hey you couldn't find a single one it's
just like you know for pretend we can
have her sit here and then
and i always joke that's why i got uh
the job
um fast forward six years later we've
changed a lot of things and how we do
things that i'm super proud of but it's
very very slow progress
um so um
i i really think there there is a
two two key elements that we need to
change and do better at
one is the element of the pipeline
coming in
uh we seem to think that oh there's not
enough women going into stem and
technology and all that and i don't
think that's the problem
akamai founded the akamai technical
academy
that i've been a huge supporter of and
what that academy does is take people
without any technical background
and teach them the things they need to
to know in order to do and join the
company and do really well at the
company there's a harvard business case
around that which i encourage you to
look up
um phenomenal progress over the five
um probably five six years that the
company has done that
uh and today i actually manage a global
team of
a lot of ata members that have grown
into
uh such positions so um i think that's
one area that where the technology
sector as a whole can do more it's not
only about the pipeline and relying on
the stem and the sciences
is how do we
give certificates do more and higher in
a in a different way i don't think we
need to hire a person
that has a computer science degree to do
all the roles that the technology
company needs there are
plenty of roles that don't require that
background and there are plenty of roles
that we can
teach people how to do so how do we do
that better that's like one
area and then the second area
is how do we uh support the progression
of women at the higher executive
leadership positions from director to vp
to
to the executive suite because i
i met a phenomenal woman at this women's
award event
and she had maintained like a 45
45 to 50 ratio in her
organization and i asked her how she did
that she was like
i was like how did you get to 45 50
that's like unheard of in our industry
charlie was very simple um she hired
women leaders and kept throwing them um
and
that was her answer that's all she did
she hired women leaders and kept growing
them
so it kind of proliferated through the
organization that
um that kind of focus on diversity and
giving more people a chance so i think
those are two areas where i think we can
do more
progress is made but the progress is
very very very slow
i think we're still at the 20-something
percent maybe 25 that's still
not quite there uh and there's a 20.
it's not 50 and we're 50 percent of the
population so it's it's
51.
it's not even it should be 50. and those
are the jobs of the future i think
that's the second
element is there's so much opportunity
there that we've got to make a change
there we've got to make a change here
and i particularly like that that second
statement because it resonates a lot
to to a great case study that i that i
read about
talking about venture capital and and
founding teams
and investing more in in female founders
and in minority founders in general and
one of the one of the
findings of the case study was that uh
the
one of the real ways to just make it
happen is the real
the starting point is to have more
females as managing partners of these
funds
it's not enough to to go to these you
know uh
to to go to these guys that are managing
the funds and say you should invest in
more women and more minorities
but having women and minorities in
leadership positions from the get-go
growing them in their leadership
positions
helping them both inspire and help
elevate
other others into that position i think
i think that's
remarkable what do you really get
excited about what
really turns you on when you go to work
either with customers or managing teams
or or working with with with you know
elevating people around the world
what really gets you excited um i think
i'm just a passionate person
uh in general and i for me like my
latest passion is
really this uh like this diversity angle
doing more in that and and really
growing people
i i think maybe that's my biggest
passion just growing people giving
people the opportunity to grow
um and i'm lucky that i get to do that
i love it what would be one tip that i
should take with me
in this idea in this world of growing
people
you know i aspire to be a good leader i
aspire to have the privilege to
to work with people you know in an
organization that i will help
grow from very young what do i need to
to intentionally do
in order to help people grow alongside
me
find their strengths find their
strengths i i fundamentally believe that
there are
no kind of bad people or bad employees
or what have you i think there's usually
just like a wrong mismatch like a wrong
fit to a specific position like
someone's doing something they're just
not
intending to do so when you think about
people you think about what are they
really really good at what are they
really good at and then find those roles
that are kind of
fitting to their strengths i love it
limon thank you so so much for coming on
i love this conversation and
both hearing your own journey but but
also gaining more perspective
in the world of growing people and
ecosystem in general i have a few fun
questions are you ready
i'm ready let's go all right number one
what was your favorite subject in school
math math for sure
it's a very it's either right or wrong
it's very easy you don't have to guess
[Laughter]
i love it what who is one of your role
models fictional or real
uh my husband my husband
he's my high school sweetheart uh
really yeah so he is uh
he is positive no matter what the
situation
and he like i think that
positivity is just so inspiring to have
positivity in your life is
something really important so he's my
role model for sure
i love it and the final question it's
not the most important one but it is the
the hardest i think for a lot of people
what are three words that you would use
to describe yourself
uh my first one is passionate which i
think we talked about in this interview
um genuine for sure uh
you see what you get there's not a lot
beyond and then
usually people tend to tell me i'm smart
so i'm gonna go with that one
thank you so so much thank you so much
i'm taking a lot a lot of lessons here
for myself and
i'm sure this will be so enjoyable for
so many people so thank you for
for coming on and sharing your insights
with me and stay safe and stay healthy